[MUSIC PLAYING]
ENO COMPTON: You might have
heard about Google Cloud
Functions, which makes
it possible to write
simple, single-purpose code that
scales automatically and runs
in response to events.
You might also be wondering,
does it work with Go?
ANGELA FUNK: Cloud Functions
recently announced support
for Python 3.7 and Node 8.
And today, we're excited to
show you the newly released Go
support for Cloud Functions.
Let's get started.
ENO COMPTON: Go Cloud Functions
come in two distinct types--
HTTP functions and
background functions.
Let's take a look at
an HTTP function first.
HTTP functions run when
they receive a request
and they return a response.
The function signature follows
the HTTP handler func interface
from the Go standard
library, meaning
that you can use the wide
variety of Go HTTP middleware
right out of the box.
ANGELA FUNK: Now
let's deploy it.
We give our function
a name, hello,
specify the entry point, F,
and add the trigger HTTP flag.
Once it's deployed,
your command line
will show the URL used
to trigger the function.
Just copy that in your
browser to test it.
And with that, we've just
deployed our first Go Cloud
Function.
ENO COMPTON: Next, let's take a
look at a background function.
While an HTTP function
responds to a request,
a background function
responds to an event.
Let's write a
function that triggers
every time a cloud storage
bucket's contents change.
Here's what our
function looks like.
It receives a
cloud storage event
and logs the file
in bucket name.
ANGELA FUNK:
Deployments function
is just like deploying
an HTTP function.
We give our function a name,
specify the entry point,
and specify the event
type and resource
that originates the event.
Now with all the setup
complete, this function
will fire every time a new
file is added to our bucket.
Don't forget to create
the cloud storage bucket
before deploying your function.
Now, to test this,
just use the web UI
and upload a file
to your bucket.
ENO COMPTON: We've only
shown a very small piece
of what's possible with
Go Cloud Functions.
With Cloud Functions,
you don't have
to worry about
server management.
You only pay for what you
use, and your functions
scale automatically
in response to demand.
Best of all, you're using
the familiar building
blocks of Go functions.
ANGELA FUNK: Using
Go Cloud Functions,
you can build mobile or IoT
back ends, virtual assistants
or chat bots, do
real-time file processing,
or integrate with third-party
services, just to name a few.
What's best, though, is
that it's incredibly easy
to get started by writing
a small function in Go
and then building
it up from there.
ENO COMPTON: We hope you give
Go Cloud functions a try.
I'm Eno Compton.
ANGELA FUNK: And I'm Angela.
Let us know how it goes by
leaving questions or comments
in the section below.
ENO COMPTON: Reach
out to us on Twitter,
and don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud Platform
YouTube channel
for more Go videos.
ANGELA FUNK: See you next time.
ENO COMPTON: Thanks
for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]